here we are with actual actors a
moderate special effects budget and
several low-level x-men none of the big
ones though we got to save something for
Phase two hey everybody it's Charlie
this is gonna be my full review video of
Deadpool - there will be spoilers so if
you haven't seen the movie yet just
careful for spoilers we'll be talking
about very specific details Easter eggs
cameos everything if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos they'll be
giveaway stuff that I'll explain at the
end of the video - so starting it off
I'll just have to say far and away love
this movie more than I love the first
movie one of those examples of a sequel
that winds up being better than the
original movie they found a way to
market us this giant big team up movie
give us a little bit of that while at
the same time subverting that
expectation and keeping it small and
intimate like the first deadpool movie
just the main ones one of my favorite
lines after everybody crashes after they
parachute out of the back of the plane
so this film parodies sequels in as much
as it parodies itself as well as the
x-men franchise and every other big
comic book franchise there is part of
the fun for me is trying to pick out
Easter eggs and pop culture jokes when I
go to see things so obviously this was
wall-to-wall pop culture jokes there
were a couple moments when you could
definitely tell they swapped in some
joke changes at the last minute any time
where he's wearing his mask doing a
one-liner is probably something that
they changed later in the edit they said
that Ryan Reynolds was sending them new
jokes in post-production right up until
the last day so they were kind of stuck
with some of the jokes that they set up
pretty early like the frozen Yentl joke
Papa can you hear me it that they later
paid off at the end of the film because
he was slowly going out some of that was
in service of the emotional through line
the whole idea the Deadpool in Vanessa
wanted to start a family that they then
later spun into the f-word which is
basically the x-force team family is an
f-word so I feel like they did a better
job of that than they did in the first
film well at the same time cranking all
the jokes up and you could definitely
tell they spent a lot more money on the
special effects fire fist negasonic they
spent more money to do the x-jet they
flew that around a lot more than they
did in the first film they had all those
special cameos from the x-men member so
I do think they did a really good job
with the infinity war of it all just
talking about like the
really big crazy say like what Conda
style battles when everything just goes
nuts on screen they found a way to still
make that funny especially the parachute
scene when everybody's powers are going
off especially working in jokes like the
Vanisher where you're like what the hell
is Brad Pitt doing in this movie oh very
clearly they added him at the last
minute but it was such a great moment
seriously one of the jokes that they
considered instead of doing the Vanisher
was actually having Chris Evans
fantastic for Human Torch character come
to audition for the team
the Vanisher was the joke that they
ended up landing on because they could
just put anybody they wanted to in
post-production when he landed on the
wires
speaking of CG characters we have to
talk about the juggernaut if you guys
didn't know it's a completely motion
capture character just like Colossus but
is actually Ryan Reynolds himself doing
the voice of the juggernaut but I
thought they did a really good job of CG
creature versus CG creature when you
have his battle with Colossus and they
gave Colossus a real art to he actually
feels like much more of a buddy than
cable does which is like one of the
things that was weird about the film to
me in that cable is supposed to be such
a big character going forward five
picture contract that Josh Brolin signed
they have an arc for him plan through
four films I don't know what that fifth
film is gonna wind up being but he's
such a huge character I felt like they
would double down on him and cable a
little bit more than they actually did
but they did say that they bumped up the
cable in the movie during the reshoots
there apparently was way less cable
before they did that so I think the
scenes that they added later in
post-production were him with weasel the
stuff with him by himself looking at the
techno-organic virus there's that moment
where he's staring into the mirror and
it looks kind of like he's in pain or
he's worried he's not really sure what
he's going to look like in a couple
years because the virus is getting worse
the writers did say that they would
address that in future sequels obviously
x-force Deadpool three there have been
jokes like they make a lot of jokes
during the film about future sequels why
don't we just skip the third one there's
no point in doing it like they joke that
they'll skip to Deadpool for instead of
doing Deadpool three so everybody that's
talked about it has said that the
lawyers will not let them talk to the
Marvel people the writers of the
Deadpool movie have actually tried to
contact Kevin Feige but I think Ryan
Reynolds and crew have such a great ship
running that they're not going to try
and mess with that too much once they
are under
Kevin Feige banner but a lot of you are
wondering about the X force of it all so
the one of the biggest complaints that I
saw on my non-spoilery review after
people had started to see it
internationally was that they were
expecting something more from the
x-force team up because it was billed as
Deadpool and x-force so people just
expected it to be a straight-up
superhero sequel team-up movie and the
funny thing is I think that we should
not have been surprised by how they
pulled the rug out from under us with
those characters because Deadpool is
meant to subvert superhero movie tropes
in him forming a super duper group that
was very derivative per dominos comment
of the x-men team just felt like a trope
so it was obviously the set up for a big
punch line that was them all dying while
they were parachuting down the pace of
the movie did slowed down a little bit
after that big opening scene so actually
we should talk about the opening credits
too in the same way that the first movie
did funny opening credits that weren't
really opening credits second movie to
the exact same thing it was more of a
James Bond opening if you're not a big
James Bond movie fan just watch it the
first 10 minutes of one of those movies
and you'll see what I'm talking about
but the Logan call-out was great there
was so much Hugh Jackman in this film
even though he himself was nowhere to be
found
all of the Hugh Jackman that you saw
during that post-credit scene which is
footage from the original Wolverine
Origins movie they just cut it in a
really funny way to work Deadpool in so
it looked like it was new footage of him
just cleaning up the timelines I'll post
a link to my post credit scene video at
the end of this because probably one of
the best comic book post-credit scenes
of all time especially considering that
Infinity Ward just happened and we got
that bombshell of a post-credits scene
they have more of a serious moment with
a little bit of comedy in it Deadpool is
obviously all for comedy there were a
couple jokes that didn't quite land as
well as I thought they could have they
drug his death scene at the end of the
film on just a little longer than I
expected them to I was expecting a
little more of a smash cut to speed
through cable using his time Turner to
go back and save him and because of what
he does with time-travel at the end of
the film a lot of people are like hey
wait a minute how does this change the
timeline of the film so just assume that
Vanessa will be alive when we get to the
next Deadpool movie and Peter but nobody
else as far as we know people always get
really worked up about the rules of
time-travel because if cable and
Deadpool
prevented fire fist from becoming the
villain in the future and his family was
saved wouldn't then cable never have
come back in the first place so wouldn't
he just vanish in front of their eyes
but he stays there
so if cable didn't vanish then just
assumed relatively fluid time-travel
rules meaning that Vanessa can be alive
and Peter can be alive after the
post-credits scenes while at the same
time the events of them putting x-force
together and those members dying can
stick so that when we get to Drew
Goddard's x-force later this year he can
pick whichever team members that he
wants the music was great even though
they didn't have junkie XL it was Tyler
Bates doing the score they had that
funny juggernaut song that was probably
one of the funnier Easter eggs within
the universe because just listened to
the lyrics for a second here
holy [ __ ] and then there were all
the jokes about dubstep and then the
dubstep music they used in the film when
they were fighting there were a couple
moments when cable wasn't quite as funny
as I felt like he could have been so I
feel like they need to tweak that a
little bit for the x-force movie in any
Deadpool sequels because he's funnier
when he is not telling jokes and I felt
like they tried to give him too many
actual jokes Deadpool is meant to be the
one to do all the wisecracking the cable
reacts to but the problem is is that
Colossus already does that so you have
this weird group dynamic with cable in
there so they just need to tune that a
little bit because you have two big
strong guys although I love the way they
make fun of the fact the cable is not as
tall as comic-book cable Deadpool
specifically calls that out during the
film 511 not big like comic book cable
so it was hilarious at the end of the
film when you see them all walking into
frame tallest to shortest so you have
Colossus then Deadpool is a little bit
shorter than Josh Brolin's cable who's a
lot shorter than Bryan Reynolds Deadpool
so they're like this weird Russian
nesting doll and speaking of Russian
jokes I did like the actual jokes that
they gave for Colossus to tell because
he has funny moments and then there are
actually genuine jokes that he tells
that's how we do it in Mother Russia and
then he drops an f-bomb for Deadpool he
jams the wire of juggernauts but then
pushes him into the pool so I love
Colossus so much more than I loved him
in the first film I was a big fan of the
first film that should be clear but I
think that all the characters were
better in the sequel there were a couple
of minor funny cameo moments you may
have spotted Matt Damon in alan tudyk
when cable first ported into the past
they were the rednecks who cable stole
the car from so let me know in the
comments what did you think about the
film what did you think about some of
the funnier cameos in the jokes
obviously I'll do an Easter Egg video
but I'll talk about all the specific
cameos a lot of people are still
wondering about where Stanley was in the
film there is a new round of that black
panther blu-ray giveaway all you have to
do to enter just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video I'll name a
winner when I post that Easter egg video
tomorrow but click here for the post
credit scene and click here for that
brand new infinity war eternal scene
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]